- Discipline.
- Hello, Believe nation.
Today we're going to talk about how
you can develop discipline.
And as always, guys,
as you're watching if you hear something
that really inspires you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it as well
so other people can be inspired
and when you write it down
it's much more likely to
sync in for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(theme music)
- So Tony, one of the critics
actually that I once met said,
"Yeah, Tony's techniques,
"they were great for
about a year and a half
"and then they wore off."
- [Tony] (laughs)
- What do you say to that?
- It is what it is.
It's real simple,
if you don't work out you
don't get muscle, right?
So I always tell people
there's a daily practice,
like priming.
If you don't do that,
if you get up and you just
have no discipline whatsoever
you get no value of anything.
Diets don't work when you don't do them,
exercise doesn't work
when you don't do them.
But, most of the people
have some experiences
that they want to shift,
and once you shift those
things your whole life changes.
But, life is constant growth.
My life isn't here because I
went to one seminar one time
and now my life is fit for life.
I work out,
I train my mind,
I train my body,
it becomes a lifestyle.
It's not just the,
like you're depending upon somebody else.
I'm not here to become somebody's guru,
I'm not here to give them a gift.
I'm here to help them
open up their own gifts,
an that's really what my work has been.
- I've never met a person
who was not successful
that didn't have a great
amount of self-discipline
within their life.
Self-discipline and being able to perform
and being able to keep
your life on schedule
commitments and promises
and meet deadlines is
essential to success.
None of us,
none of us can afford to have
a life that is controlled
by someone else or a
life that is basically
controlled by our emotions.
I learned many years ago that
there are two kinds of people.
There's the type of person who says,
"I'm going to wait until I
feel like it before I do it."
And then there's the person who says,
"I've got to do it so
that I feel like it."
One will never get anything done
because they're still waiting
to feel the moment to move
and the other person that says,
"No, I need to move and then
"I will begin to feel the moment."
Self-discipline is the
essential in your life
and in my life if we're
going to get things done.
So I have a challenge for
every one of you this weekend.
The challenge is simple.
As you go through your weekend
and sometimes it's kind of a,
hopefully an easier time of your week,
ask yourself,
"Am I practicing
self-discipline in my life?
"Am I doing the things that I should do
"because I need to do them
or am I kind of waiting
"to feel the moment?"
Do like our friends Nike say.
Just do it.
- [Interviewer] How different
do you think your career
and possibly your life would have been
had you not embraced the
physical fitness part early on?
- Oh man.
You know, it just gives me,
between my physical fitness and my faith
I have so much discipline in my life.
And I have such a positive
outlook on life and you know,
the opportunities that I have
and the things that I've been
able to accomplish in my life.
So it starts out you know,
I'm up at 4:30 in the morning,
I'm in the kitchen having breakfast,
5:00 I'm in the gym,
6:30 I've already had another shake
and 7:30 I'm eating a
couple turkey burgers,
dropping the kids off at school
and by 9:00 I'm having another meal
and I've already been
to church and worked out
and you know,
I feel like there isn't anything
that I can't accomplish.
- When I was in high school,
I must've been maybe 16 or 17 years old.
And I went rock climbing
in El Dorado Canyon,
near where I grew up in Boulder.
I'd been climbing about
three or four years
and I went to do a climb called T2.
Now at the time,
T2 was a relatively difficult climb
and I went at it with a,
kind of an arrogant lack of preparation.
And I hadn't prepared for
being able to do certain kinds
of finger cracks,
I figured, "Oh, I'll figure
it out when I get there."
And I also didn't pause,
and this is the thing about
boldness and discipline,
I didn't pause to really
double check all my systems.
Okay.
So I'm on the fourth pitch,
I'm about 400 feet above the ground.
I'm going across the slanting crack system
that I'd started to have trouble with
and my forearm started to engorge
with blood and lactic acid.
Which meas at some point,
even if you're on a big hold,
your hands are going to melt off.
Okay.
And I'm about to fall.
I'm 400 feet above the ground.
But it should be okay
because there's protection,
I'm tied into the rope.
I may take a fall but I'll get caught.
For some reason,
and to this day I still don't know why,
my brain triggered that
I should look at my knot.
And I looked down at my knot.
My knot had come untied.
I had made the mistake of
never really thinking about
the best knot for certain
types of situations
and I tied in with what's a bowline.
Now the advantage of a
bowline is it's easy to untie.
Right?
The disadvantage of a bowline
is it's easy to untie.
It had come untied as
I kept moving across,
and it is just hanging in my harness.
I'm seconds away from falling,
only now I will die.
I will die if I fall off.
My forearms are melting.
And the knot had come untied,
and so I called down to my partner,
I said, "My know came untied."
What is he going to do?
He can't do anything,
he'll just watch me fall to my death.
And I,
there was an old fixed piton in the rock
that was put there from the first descent,
an old soft iron piton.
And I looked at it,
and I probably had 15,
20 seconds before my hands would unwrap,
if that,
maybe 10.
I took a runner and I
clipped it into the piton
and I clipped the piton into my,
that runner into my harness
and just went, "Please hold."
And I let go.
And it held.
I put in a backup,
I grabbed the knot,
retied it,
went to the ledge,
I didn't convulse.
I was very calm at that moment.
When I got to the ledge I
went into convulsive shaking.
I was sick to my stomach for days
because of whatever happens chemically.
What I learned from that is two things.
The first is that when you're
in an unforgiving world
and gravity is unforgiving,
it doesn't care.
It never takes a day off, ever.
And if you make one
mistake it can kill you,
if it's the wrong kind of mistake.
And what I learned is that sense of yeah,
I want to do adventurous things,
I want to climb rocks,
I want to be in Yosemite,
I want to do things that
get my adrenaline going.
But, I need the discipline to always do
all the right preparation.
To always think about the right knots,
to always be cross-checking my system
so that I can do those bold things
and stay alive in an
unforgiving environment.
And as you and I spoke
about earlier today,
I think that's the recipe,
I think we are all heading
into an unforgiving environment
where we're going to have to
be both bold and disciplined.
The second thing I learned.
What if that piton had not been there?
We might not be here together.
It was just by chance that
that piton was right there.
I want you to realize
when you rewind the tape
of your own life is that there
are these crucial moments
where if the luck had gone the other way,
you might have gotten killed.
And so what you have to do is to always be
putting those extra disciplines in place,
because I was lucky to live.
And what I took from that is
I never want to have to
be lucky to live again.
I want to live because of my discipline,
not because of my luck.
- Going on perhaps a decade
of running simultaneously
two global companies,
how do you get the stamina to keep going
and to stay fit,
you know, personally and
mentally and physically?
- Well you know,
somebody said with a little
discipline you do little things.
With a lot of discipline
you do a lot of things
and with the discipline there's
nothing which you cannot do.
It requires a lot of discipline.
I mean,
obviously because you're
going to move from one work
to the other,
from one culture to the other,
from two completely different companies.
You have jet lag,
disorganization.
People are expecting you when
you come down from a plane
after 14 hours flight to be
fresh and ready for them.
They're not expecting to
see you to come and say,
"Oh my god, this jet lag."
You cannot answer the question.
They want you to be on
the go all the time.
So, this requires a lot of discipline.
You have to organize yourself.
If you know you're going to do this job
and you accept the job you
have to organize yourself
in order to do it.
It's tough,
but there is a solution.
There is a solution for it.
But, it requires a lot of choices,
personal choices.
There are a lot of things you cannot do.
You know?
There are a lot of things you can do,
but you're going to do them
within a certain order,
but particularly with a lot of discipline.
- In 2009 when the mix tape,
and there was a period where
I think around that time
you were kind of like,
"Is this something that's
going to work for me or not?"
What is it that got you through,
how'd you work through that?
- Yeah, it's tough to
say exactly what it was.
It was hard work,
it was discipline,
it was knowing that if
this doesn't work out
then I will have to get a nine to five.
And I don't want to do that,
I really don't want to do that.
And it was working with
Ryan and putting everything
into the music,
and you know, for,
I mean leading up to
that point I think that
you have to look at my track record.
I had always wanted to get sober,
I could never get sober.
I couldn't make music while
I was under the influence
of drugs or alcohol.
Finally got sober in 2008,
got out of rehab and was like,
alright this is it.
I've wasted years of my life
and if this is going to
work it has to work now.
There is no alternative.
And I met somebody that had
the same dedication as me.
That put everything into the music,
everything into the craft,
and didn't go out,
they didn't really have many friends.
(laughter)
Just kidding,
just kidding.
We only hang out with each other.
No, its somebody that
wasn't going to you know,
be like, you know,
up until that point I was
making music with people
that were constantly putting
their priorities into getting--
- Cooler people.
- Getting,
no, not at all.
Getting loaded or chasing
women or whatever,
and that's what I did for a long time
and it didn't,
it led me to being broke and in rehab
and moving back into my parents' house.
Which is awesome,
but I wanted a career
and Ryan was somebody
that had the same discipline
and sacrificed everything.
- What my dad always told
us when we were growing up
that if you end a dollar,
you don't save anything.
If you end it beyond the
light you won't save anything.
And so, that discipline of investment,
keeping something,
don't consume everything you get,
actually helped me significantly.
- Those star moments that you know,
fill the highlight reels and you know,
leave an audience in awe to watch,
"Oh wow, play that again,
I want to see that."
Those seconds are built
on thousands and thousands
and thousands of hours that a
lot of people wouldn't think
are worth adding to a highlight reel.
Basic fundamentals being
applied over and over
and over again.
Getting up a certain time,
doing certain things,
cooking your meals,
going to you know,
do your cardio,
walking through the disciplines,
keeping the checklist,
and staying on top of them.
Those are the things that you know,
when you string them
together start to create
your day of efficient action.
The more likely you are
to string those days
of efficient action together,
the more likely it will be
that you can set up your own success.
- How would you personally describe
your style of leadership?
- Close to the human being.
I think discipline is very important,
very important,
but discipline's relative.
Especially when I work
together with young players.
Yeah, never lose the target.
I don't know how to say it,
never lose the target.
Always stay focused on it,
and so that's pretty good
because that's always, yeah.
Think it's still possible.
So there's not a right word in English--
- Belief.
- Yeah, for sure belief.
It's a bit different to believe,
believe is,
you can believe in something
but you can lose belief
quite easily,
so to be stronger in that moment,
things like this.
- I always wanted to win the World Cup,
and that was the reason I started.
6And as the time went by,
I started enjoying cricket
and I started realizing
the challenges of cricket
and my coach was instrumental,
along with my brother.
My elder brother, Rajit,
to make me realize the importance
of leading a disciplined life,
a focused life,
and to make me push harder.
They found reasons,
and even towards the end of my career
I followed that formula.
If I scored runs,
let the rest of the world talk about it,
I think about the next game.
And that,
right from my school days,
became an unwritten formula,
an unwritten law at home,
that we don't talk about the last game,
we talk about next game.
And however many runs I scored,
I wanted to go out and
score more than that.
So, if I didn't score,
I would have a restless night.
If I scored runs,
I would till have a restless night
thinking that how am
I going to score more?
And that's how it all happened,
I mean I normally don't discuss numbers,
but this is something that I
must share with all of you.
Towards the end of my
school cricket career,
I'd already started playing
first class cricket.
And the last season I can probably say
that I averaged 1,025
because I only got out
once in the whole season.
(laughter)
(applause)
My brother and my coach
was instrumental in that
because every time I scored runs,
none of them said "well played" to me,
and that's why in my farewell
speech I said to my coach,
"At least now you can take a
chance by saying well done."
There are no more matches in my career.
But, something that I lived for
was appreciation for my
coach and my brother,
which never happened,
and that was something which you know,
kept me giving my best all the time.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video,
what was your favorite clip,
and what are you going
to immediately apply
to your life or to your business somehow.
Also, how have you developed discipline
and do you have any wisdom to share
that others can learn from?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Jude Gbekou,
I hope I pronounced that okay.
Thank you so much, Jude,
for picking up a copy of
my book "Your One Word",
it really, really,
really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love.
I'll see you soon.